so today has not been an amazing day we
lost out on a really good property and
auction annoyingly and I'm going to tell
the story right now so stay tuned if you
want to hear it go on my beautiful lady
so basically here's what happened okay
so we found a property we have an
absolute master plan we had it surveyed
we've got all wrapped up in there and we
did works out that we were gonna make a
profit assuming you all came off of how
much Amanda 1.2 million however my
brother went to the auction and we had
put our budget of 805 thousand pounds
and it got up to 560 he got 180 and then
everyone stock it was just my brother
and this one of the car
and in the end my brother said I owe
five he said I owe 10 my brother had to
walk away so really annoying feeling
pretty bummed out because it would've
been a really good deal however when you
go to an auction it is really important
to make your decision on what you're
going to purchase the property for and
stick to it because when you're wrapped
up in the auction room emotions are high
and when emotions are high intelligence
is low so get your figure stick to it
and remember don't let your feelings
take over because this has to be about
formulas
I'm also some guy who loves to celebrate
my successes but I also believe that you
have to learn to discipline your
disappointment before you can celebrate
your success now it's not all bad news
today because a few hours ago I did have
a phone call from one of my students and
she's just become financially free so
that's one of the 50 ish year ticked-off
and she found me when I was dressed a
little bit undi --scent but my wife
recorded the phone conversation so here
it is cover your eyes
amazing how much how much cash flow is
that going to be bringing you in them
per month so you're literally gonna be
paid the same as you were but now you're
not going to be working that is so cool
also your job yeah I noticed that you've
now quit your job as well that's so good
you know what and we should have range
like maybe a dinner or something and
then have a bit of a celebration oh well
if the champagnes on you then they did
there's got to be on me oh that's so
cool and listen I really appreciate you
you know sort of like sharing on
Facebook and encouraging everybody as
well that's really really cool because
it gives people inspiration and I'll
drop that's so cool I'm also going to
I'll drop your message when I get back
from a holiday and let's arrange your
date to meet up awesome I am
yeah we're hopes are hopping all across
the country oh we've been all over the
south coast and right now we're in
central London in a yacht yeah awesome
we'll listen and will you have a
wonderful evening and I'll catch up with
you soon god bless Cheers
if you need any help drop us a message
bye Mason
let's hit 50 of those calls I'm done for
the year
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time